I think that is something that our a
customer was to have as a possibility of
course there are certain markets that
prefer that version some others that
don't but that is something that we need
to have in our portfolio as an offer and
you can see normally you know this kind
of expectation has to be fulfilled by
our offer and you've said that you want
to double the size and sales of the
business by the end of 2019 largely
because of that launch isn't there a
danger that you change the character of
Lamborghini in the process I confirmed
that is the objective but I confirmed
that we will not change the
characteristic villain beginning one of
our value is that we have to be
exclusive so therefore we have to
dimension now one it is a super sport
car business the other one is the Super
Sport in the SUV is a new segment is a
new niche and the trade-off between the
growth and the exclusivity value is
really the change that we need to bring
home as Lamborghini but what is really
important today that the brand is really
in thermal perception growing above all
with the young generation so how will
you guard against diluting the
exclusivity of the brand
we will not dilute the exclusivity of
the brand because as I said today last
year we have achieved the record here in
terms of sales at 3,800 the SUV is a
totally different market is quite big
and we gonna be exclusio so in that
respect even if for us the numbers will
be really big you just wonder how
concerned are you about president
Trump's threats to impose tariffs on
European cars should de response to his
tarnish on steel and aluminium imports
you know our our challenge is to make
sure that we delivered the right product
and that's the only thing that we need
to be focused on of course the different
markets can apply different kind of
taxation we need to make sure that the
only answer that we can give to this
kind of situation
is to make sure that the customer loves
our car and then of course we are
talking about a niche market of course
we are talking about rich customer
therefore that is our focus do you think
American consumers are sufficiently
insensitive to price we to be able to
ride out any high tariffs from President
Trump what we can say is that if we are
delivering the right car with the right
values with the right point that our
customer
for sure the sensitivity on price will
be there but not enough to change our
strategy on the market many years of
course you ran Ferraris Formula One team
how does running a car manufacturer
differ from that what I can say is that
I want to transfer my experience in
racing here with the need of speed of
being always there that I normal without
losing too much time so we need to be
effective and we know that the cost the
competition is very strong also in this
market is there a more enjoyable job
well there is one thing that is very
good at least the weekend that the
normally was busy I can relax and watch
former one racer TV very good Thank You
tonsure great pleasure talking to you